vamos a resolver ahora un problema de
probabilidad que de hecho fue enviado a
sal por alguien que ve el canal en
inglés de canacar de mini así que bien
vamos a considerar lo siguiente tenemos
30 personas 30 personas y estas personas
son elegidas de manera aleatoria no hay
ningún ningún patrón para elegir las
digamos que es un salón de clases o algo
así y nos preguntamos bueno cuál es la
probabilidad de que al menos dos de
ellas al menos 2
compartan
su cumpleaños compartan cumpleaños fecha
de nacimiento cumpleaños y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que preguntarse
bueno cuál es la probabilidad de
alguien
tenga el mismo cumpleaños
mismo
cumpleaños
que alguien más
y alguien
más
eso estuvo largo y bueno este problema
si lo atacó como vengo atacando la
mayoría de los problemas sería un dolor
de cabeza porque fíjense no es la
probabilidad de que exactamente dos
personas compartan cumpleaños es la
probabilidad de que al menos dos
compartan cumpleaños entonces podría por
ejemplo calcular la probabilidad de que
exactamente dos compartieran su
cumpleaños luego de que tres
compartieran su cumpleaños nuevo de que
exactamente cuatro compartieron su
cumpleaños y así hasta 29 y luego 30
sería un dolor de cabeza serían
muchísimas cuentas y realmente no quiero
hacer eso así que mejor vamos a usar un
pequeño truco
este truco de hecho es bastante útil
imagínense que todos estos son los
eventos posibles son todas las posibles
combinaciones de cumpleaños que pueden
haber en este grupo de 30 personas
entonces vamos a suponer que este cacho
verde de aquí
este cacho verde son precisamente todos
los eventos donde alguien comparte
cumpleaños con alguien más
todo esto ver desde aquí son los eventos
o las formas de escoger los cumpleaños
de las personas de manera que alguien
comparta cumpleaños con alguien más y lo
que quiero encontrar es precisamente
esta probabilidad la probabilidad de que
alguien comparta cumpleaños con alguien
más la voy a anotar por ser de compartir
entonces bien qué es todo esto que está
acá afuera que es todo lo que está
dentro del rectángulo amarillo pero no
está en verde pues esto
sería el caso o los casos donde nadie
comparte cumpleaños con nadie comparte
cumpleaños
con
nadie
o lo que es lo mismo todos tienen
cumpleaños diferentes todos tienen
cumpleaños
diferentes
toda esta región de aquí es eso
vamos a escribir la probabilidad de
estar aquí en la parte roja como la
probabilidad de que sean diferentes los
cumpleaños de de diferente qué sucede
pues yo tengo que estar parado tengo que
elegir algún evento de dentro del
rectángulo amarillo esta parte ya se
hizo verde pero bueno dentro de todo
este rectángulo así que puede estar aquí
o estar acá de modo que si lo que quiero
es calcular esta probabilidad pues la
probabilidad de estar en cualquiera de
los dos de estar en cualquier parte de
este rectángulo es 1 así que la
probabilidad de estar aquí va a ser 1 -
la probabilidad de estar en lo rojo
o dicho de otro modo que quizás sea más
útil la probabilidad
de que al menos dos personas compartan
cumpleaños más la probabilidad de que
todos los cumpleaños sean en fechas
distintas
sumados me deben de dar uno porque todos
los eventos son alguno de estos dos
casos o todos los cumpleaños son
diferentes o alguien comparte cumpleaños
con alguien más y además si alguien
comparte cumpleaños con alguien más no
puede ser que todos los cumpleaños sean
distintos así que son mutuamente
excluyentes y son todos los casos pero
bueno entonces la probabilidad de que al
menos dos personas compartan cumpleaños
va a ser igual a uno menos la
probabilidad de que todos los cumpleaños
sean distintos bien vamos a calcular
entonces cuál es la probabilidad de que
todos los cumpleaños caigan en fechas
distintas y vamos a suponer que solo
tenemos dos personas persona 1 y persona
en este caso la persona 1 su cumpleaños
puede ser cualquier día del año puede
ser cualquiera de los 365 días que tiene
el año así que su cumpleaños puede ser
365 días disponibles de entre 365 días
que tiene el año que de la persona 2
pues para que el cumpleaños de la
persona 2 sea distinto desde la persona
uno ya use uno de los días así que solo
puedo elegir entre 364 días de entre 365
días que tiene el año
esta es la probabilidad de que el
cumpleaños de la persona 2 no coincida
con el de la persona 1 este producto y
cuánto es esto pues lo voy a escribir
así aunque parezca que no tiene mucho
sentido 365 por 364 entre 365 al
cuadrado y lo que quiero al no cancelar
un 365 del numerador con 1 del
denominador es que vean un patrón que
empezará a surgir
qué hay de si tengo tres personas
personas 1 personas 2 y persona 3 en ese
caso la primera persona su cumpleaños
puede ser cualquiera de los 365 días de
entre los 365 días que tiene el año la
probabilidad de su cumpleaños de la
persona 2 puede ser cualquiera de los
364 días que me quedan ya que use uno de
entre los 365 días que tiene el año la
persona 3 su cumpleaños ya hace 2 días
para las personas 1 y 2 así que su
cumpleaños tiene que caer en alguno de
los 363 10 restantes entre los 365 días
que tiene el año y esta sería la
probabilidad de que ninguna de estas
tres personas tenga su cumpleaños en la
misma fecha y cuánto es esto pues es 365
por 364 por 363
entre 365 ahora al cubo y así que qué
pasaría si continúo hasta que tengo 30
personas pues entonces en el caso de 30
personas
tendría que la probabilidad es 365 por
364 por 363 así como estaba pasando acá
y así continuaría multiplicando hasta
multiplicar 30 números así que me
detendría en el 336 esas serían 30
números y dividiría entre
la 30va potencia pero esto es muy
complicado de escribir en una
calculadora así que les pregunto
hay algún modo de escribir esto que
involucre a los factoriales
y pues sí sí lo hay pero cuál es pues
muy bien si consideramos cuánto es 365
factorial pues por definición
esto es 365 por 364 por 363 por 362 por
361 y así hasta llegar a 2 y
eventualmente a 1 ahora bien si me fijo
en este numerador sólo tengo dos
términos estos primeros dos así que
podría dividir toda esta expresión entre
trescientos sesenta y tres por 362 por
361 hasta que eventualmente multiplique
a dos por uno por dos por uno
y qué es esto de aquí pues esto de aquí
es precisamente 363 factoriales así que
esto cancelaría a esto y nos quedaríamos
exactamente con la parte que quiero pero
otra cosa que es importante es de dónde
sale este 363 pues en este caso sólo
quería dos términos arriba sólo quería
estos dos términos y 363 es precisamente
365 menos 2 así que esto lo podría decir
escribir como 365 factorial
entre 360 y 3 - 2
factorial así que todo esto
todo esto de aquí
sería igual a 365 factorial / 363 menos
2 factorial
dividido entre 365 al cuadrado
quizás déjenme repintó esto para que
parezca una potencia muy bien
qué sucede en este caso pues en este
caso de nuevo tendría 365 factorial 365
factorial pero ahora quiero 3 términos
así que voy a hacer 365 menos 3
factorial
y todo lo voy a dividir entre 365 al
cubo
y esto cuánto me dan 365 factorial es
365 por 364 por 363
por 362 etcétera etcétera dividido entre
365 3 362 factorial sería entre 362 por
361 etcétera etcétera
y todo eso entre 365
al cubo ahora bien toda esta parte de
aquí cancelaría a la parte
correspondiente de acá arriba lo que me
queda que desafortunadamente no me ocupo
y todo eso lo voy a dividir entre 365 al
cubo ok así que siguiendo esta misma
lógica estoy acá lo podría escribir como
365 factorial
/ ahora quiero 30 términos así que entre
365 menos 30 factorial dividido entre
365 a la 30va potencia la potencia 30 y
esto cuánto es ahora si voy a sacar mi
calculadora de hecho en gran medida todo
esto fue para poder escribirlo rápido en
la calculadora porque ya sé dónde está
el botón de factorial bien entonces 365
factorial entre 365 menos 30 y 335
factorial todo eso dividido entre 365
elevado a la potencia 30
y la calculadora nos dice que eso es
0.29 36 así que esto vale 0.29 36 o si
lo quiero escribir como un porcentaje es
el 29 punto 36 por ciento sólo
multiplicó por 100 y agregó el símbolo
de porcentaje pero nosotros no queríamos
la probabilidad de que las 30 personas
tuvieran un cumpleaños diferente que es
esta de aquí nosotros queríamos la
probabilidad de que compartieran un
cumpleaños al menos dos personas que
habíamos visto acá arriba que era 1 - la
probabilidad de que todos los cumpleaños
fueran distintos así que esto es 1 - la
probabilidad de que sean distintos o lo
que es lo mismo esto es 1 - 0.29 36 y
cuánto es eso
quiero uno menos los de arriba menos en
el resultado y eso es 0.7063 y algo más
así que esto fue 0.7063 o escrito como
un porcentaje fue aproximadamente el
70.6 por ciento de los casos lo cual es
bastante sorprendente de hecho esto es
bastante interesante porque si pones a
30 personas en un cuarto y te preguntas
cuál es la probabilidad de que comparta
un cumpleaños en principio uno esperaría
que fuera un número relativamente bajo
pero es bastante alto de hecho la
mayoría de las veces vas a compartir
cumpleaños con alguien en tu grupo de
clases si es que tu clase tiene al menos
30 personas claro pero bueno espero les
haya gustado este vídeo